hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
möchte heute mal wieder einen leckeren
klassiker machen und zu den klassikern
bei uns in der familie und bei uns in
der umgebung gehört die fanta schnitte
und zwar ist die fahnder schnitte ein
sehr lockerer teig mit fanta natürlich
kann man auch einfach eine andere
limonaden benutzen aber daher zahlt der
namen fand abschnitte dann kommen noch
40 stücke betreiben und eine leckere
schwanz creme oben drauf und ich zeige
euch jetzt einmal ganz kurz die zutaten
für den teig ich brauche drei eier 100
gramm zucker etwas vanille extrakt eine
prise salz
hier habe ich 80 auf 100 gramm fanta
also 100 milliliter 80 liter öl das ist
jetzt ein sonnenblumenöl ich habe ich
100 gramm mehl und 100 gramm
speisestärke und ich brauche 15
teelöffel backpulver und jetzt starte
ich auch direkt mit dem teig und gäbe es
die eier in eine rührschüssel es jetzt
mit der küchenmaschine ein handrührgerät
geht auch da kommt der zucker mit rein
eine prise salz und etwas vanille
extrakt wie immer es wird jetzt ganz
kurz schaumig gerührt
jetzt ist die eier masse schön weiß
cremig und jetzt gebe ich die beiden
flüssigkeiten öl und fanta mit dazu und
es ruhig jetzt ganz kurz mal niedriger
stufe 1
und jetzt kommen noch die trockenen
zutaten mit rein und die gebe ich jetzt
durch einen sieg damit ich einfach keine
klümpchen mit der zeit habt jetzt noch
15 teelöffel backpulver
und dadurch die zutaten jetzt ganz kurz
mit einem schneebesen vorsichtig ein
jetzt würde ich den teig in eine
vorbereitete backform hiermit den bug
kamen auf 26 cm eingestellt und habe ihn
mit backpapier bereits eingeschlagen
der backofen ist auch vorgeheizt auf 175
grad ober unterhitze und so wird der
teig jetzt für etwa 30 minuten gebacken
der kuchenteig ist abgekühlt und den
setze ich jetzt mit hilfe meiner meines
torten retters auf eine tortenplatte und
da kommt jetzt auch direkt der
tortenring wieder aus herum
die muss man vorher nicht austauschen
ich habe einfach innen so bis in die
krümel weggenommen kann ich kurz zur
seite stellen und zeigt jetzt hier vorne
kurz die zutaten für die füllung und für
obendrauf
also ich hab jetzt hier eine dose 40
hatte habe ich jetzt bereits abtropfen
lassen
hier habe ich zwei beherrsche wand also
400 gramm 200 g schlagsahne etwas
vanille extrakt 100 gramm puderzucker
und sahen ab hart und ich stelle jetzt
zuerst mal die creme her und zwar gebe
ich den schwan jetzt hier in eine
schüssel haider geht es natürlich viel
besser manchmal michalak aus springe aus
den chancen welche
dann gebe ich da den puderzucker mit
rein und den ziemlich jetzt kurz durch
damit sich einfach diese klümpchen nicht
mit drin hab und gut zu geld auch besser
als normaler zucker war dass ich einfach
direkt in der creme mit auflösen
man kommentiere vier teelöffel seiner
fahrt mit rein vier flache teelöffel so
und das wird jetzt hier gleichstrom
verwirrt aber ich stehe in der
zwischenzeit auch schon mal die sahne
vorbereiten kann ich nämlich beides
parallel machen also seine auch hier in
eine große schüssel des schlages
getrennt voneinander steif und vanille
extrakt gebe ich noch hier mit rein
jetzt kann ich die sahne schon mal etwas
anrühren und gibt dann noch zwei
teelöffel sein apartment rein und lassen
der zwischenzeit auch schon mal hier die
creme so ein bisschen rühren
jetzt kann ich die sahne unter die
schmandt creme heben und entspannt
dürften nicht zu lange röhren weil je
länger er will und so flüssiger wird
deswegen einfach nur ganz kurz bis sich
man seiner tat und puderzucker vermengt
haben unterhalten
jetzt kann ich die sahne creme ganz kurz
kühl stellen und der zwischenzeit schon
mal die vier sich fein würfeln
jetzt kann ich die stücke direkt auf dem
kuchen boden verteilen
und da macht es auch nichts passieren
ein bisschen feucht sinn weil wir
einfach die feuchtigkeit bisschen auch
in den teig ich verteile ich jetzt ganz
locker mit einem löffel
und jetzt kommt nur noch die schmucken
drauf und wird dann auch gut verteilt
und jetzt wird die torte noch abgedeckt
und muss dann in den kühlschrank für
mindestens drei stunden
ihr könnt sie auch über nacht in den
kühlschrank stellen und danach zeige ich
euch nicht
die karte ist jetzt schön kalt und jetzt
löst sich den torten ganzen kuchen den
macht man eigentlich im blech also fand
abschnitte wird eigentlich von einem
ganz normalen backblech gemacht aber ich
finde es etwas schöner in einem runden
backwaren aber ein blech geht natürlich
auch cool du kennt es bestimmt auch als
chance und kuchen den macht man immer da
gibt so bleiben sagte er
ich kenne den kufen neu kennen auch oder
ich dachte erst ich kind nicht aber ich
kenne ihn bei uns war es früher die
freeware schnitt also wir hatten kein
geld
originalteile und teilen jetzt hier mal
zwölf stücke ein
finde ich auch optisch oder ganz hübsch
und dann kommt noch etwas impuls
vertraut studie des musters susi ich
probier's morath ich muss ich ganz
ehrlich drauflegen weil es sich ein
feuchter als eine creme das probier s
mal gespannt ob das funktioniert
funktioniert es üblich ist nur auf die
fantasie
ja ich finde es also ich bin total das
muss also das unterstrichen und sind
jetzt nicht einmal so salz und zucker
jetzt kann sie auch direkt anschneiden
also ich bin zimtpulver geht auf jeden
fall mit dazu das macht den geschmack
total aus durch richtige klasse
entwickelt weiß nicht ob man denn
überall kennt oder ob es den am besten
ist es wenn man den kuchen am tag im
kühlschrank lässt der stadt noch sehr
frisch sehr locker auch wirklich sehr
locker sind super teig und gut abstützen
probiere mich lieb mich ein bisschen
lesen mitunter gespannt also ich find
die torte sehr lecker und
ich fand es fantastisch also wir kennen
das mit 40 stücken aber mal ich kenne
auch die version mit mandarinen stücken
ich denke man könnte auch kirschen zum
beispiel nehmen aber 30 40
diese hellen früchte passen einfach gut
zu diesem van dyk und vor allem das im
pulver passt wirklich gut
richtig schnell gemacht also ich denke
zubereitungszeit hat man vielleicht eine
halbe stunde aber die kühe zeit hat man
natürlich noch wie gesagt kann man gut
vorbereiten am tag vorher einfach den
kühlschrank geben und kurz vor dem
servieren dann das sind pulver mit drauf
geben
und falls ihr das rezept nach macht
schreibt mir gerne nein dann könnt ihr
nachlesen auf cellestis blog.de und ihr
könnt mir mal schreiben ob wir den
kuchen schon vorher kannte tops denn
auch für euch gibt vielleicht heißt er
auch bei euch irgendwie anders kann sie
auch sein
murat das war von pfirsich schalten ja
motor abgestorben
hier passiert schon nichts ja und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken und wir sehen uns dann das
nächste mal wieder biss dann tschüss
möchte von kollegen vielleicht gibt es
auch mal eine cola kuchen
vielleicht gibt es sowas sind schreibt
mir weil ich möchte mit dir reden aber
dortmund fragte ich ständig da einfach
nichts mehr hin so ist das möchte mir eh
nix 12